okay after eight grilling months I
have stopped working for Mr Beast
holy [__] [__]
in this video I give you an exclusive look
into what it is like working at Beast
The hours,
the stress, the the plane rides, the travel,
the wins the fails true examination behind
the curtain I'm in Chile and I've got a new
training partner let's go he's gonna get jacked
This will be exciting!
Perfect!
But first thereason I stopped
working for Mr Beast is because
because I had a little baby boy meet Seth today
is his one week birthday so technically I've only
stopped or paused working for Mr Beast for the
next month yes subtle clickbait but you can't get
triggered when looking at this cute little face
look look at this tiny nose, these eyes hands andtoes
So this is how we do it at Beast everything
I've learned over the past eight months combined
into five secret never revealed before formulas
on how to make practically any video go viral
even if you only have one subscriber but before
going back eight months I have some really exciting
news along with House of Macs I have developed
my very own Super tasty caffeinated bar called
the BRU Bar my first ever product one of these
bad boys and you'll be wide awake and alert for
the entire day or night depending on what you
use it for I'll tell you more about it at the
end of this video but it's by far the greatest
thing I've ever made and I'm super proud of it
Okay, so after finding out Gabby was pregnant
on a SAT phone in Antarctica I flew back to
South Africa and after 53 hours of grueling
travel I made it to my beautiful pregnant
wife for a short trip because I had to move to
Greenville North Carolina to start off my new
position as Chief Creative Officer at Beast
Philanthropy which is a dream job a once in
a lifetime opportunity so Gabs granted me
three months, three months to fly there set
up an entire Studio to make it possible to
work from two opposite sides of the world so
I arrived at this undisclosed location that
was fully kitted out except for this room
one day later with three BRU Bars down
it became a pretty rad set up I'd say
this is where the next eight months of
chaos would begin
then it was time for
me to fly back to Cape Town I set up this
studio along with a South African team
I shot a form where we gave away 20 000 shoes
to kids in need we got 20 million views on this
video success then back to Greenville to
shoot Mr Beast and Darren on a blue screen
for 3D comps back to Cape Town to check in
on Gaby and the pregnancy
I wanted a boy
then to Cambodia to give away 2 000
Prosthetics to amputees in need then
back to South Africa to check on Gabs as well
as where I lost a bet and how to get Darren's
name tattooed on my shoulder and then back to
Greenville North Carolina and did some yoga
two remote island Colombia to power it and set up
Wi-Fi and a bakery where I fell in a river filled
with crocodiles in back to Cape Town where I broke
my wrist gotta go to Kenya in three days I've been
to Kenya to give away a bunch of e-bikes to water
delivery men and I capsized another boat then back
to Cape Town where it was getting super close to
the birth so I quickly flew to the Philippines
to a children's hospital where we paid for
150 surgeries and then back to Cape Town just
in time for the birth it happened on the 18th of
June 2023 which was Father's Day and that's just
something you can't script gabs gave birth to the
perfect little boy named Seth
and that brings me
to today what I've learned working for Mr Beast
over the last eight months five hidden secrets
he has taught me to make anything go viral even
Philanthropy videos which have in the past been
described as boring they've been described as
fatiguing before taking this job most people
told me that this just wasn't gonna work again
just for the record I am still the current Chief
Creative Officer of Beast Philanthropy I'm just
taking some time off a month or so to spend some
valuable time with my son before I tell you the
five hidden secrets Mr Beast has taught me on
how to make literally any video go viral I want
to tell you more about BRU Bar the BRU Bar was
made in collaboration with House of M acadamias an
incredible company with a bunch of people I now
consider really close friends but most importantly
they are the best tasting nut of all time this
true so technically with the Brew Bar we're kind
of cheating because macadamias are just so tasty
so you can add anything to it I don't know it
still tastes great this has been spoken about by
Joe Rogan "House of Macadamia" Lex Fridman "House
of Macadamias" and more yeah I'm no health nut
but the BRU Bar contains rare Omega-7s which
makes your skin glow and helps with fat loss it
increases gut health it is super low carb it has
heart healthy fats and it is fully plant-based oh
and it has a [__] ton of caffeine not too much
but just enough to give you a really good kick
so click on the link in the top line
of the description to buy yours now
the first hundred people to buy two boxes of
BRU Bars get a free variety pack of additional
House of macadamia bars as well as free shipping
and furthermore if you use the code BRU I'll be
donating 100% of the profits to Beast philanthropy
okay as promised here are the five never taught
before secrets to going viral Mr Beast taught me
while working with him collaborate versus compete
even though he is the most followed individual on
YouTube he still never lets us get to his head he
understands that he is still young and does not
know everything often times he leans on multiple
mentors in different fields of his company whether
it is business storytelling branding and marketing
psychology Etc he understands he can no longer
do it alone and that's why he has more than 200
employees but remember that he started all alone
in his bedroom many years ago with a super shitty
camera Jimmy often invites other YouTubers around
to Greenville whether they are highly followed or
have a micro audience that he sees an X Factor
to learn from he values others opinions I won't
lie but before I started working there I had a
completely different idea of Jimmy I just thought
he was the kind of person that told people what
to do and how to do it even with an unfathomably
brilliant mind he takes advice from pretty much
anyone and on the other side of the coin he also
gives back by helping grow tons of others channels
by collaborating with him but he constantly makes
time to be involved in other creators videos
whether it's shorts or longer form at the end
of the day the reason with no argument the best in
the world is because he never stops learning and
he never lets himself believe that he is indeed
the best virality is not an accident it's a skill
as creators we often blame the algorithm for not
going viral or for videos performing poorly to
your standard I know I do it's usually the videos
that I think are the best my best videos get the
least amount of views, and being friends with a lot of
other creators in the space this is like one of
the most common things with most of us although
the algorithm does have a major part to play in
the virality of your content it is not the be-all
and end-all at the end of the day tough pill to
swallow here if your video did not perform well
it's on you not on the algorithm one is that your
shitty title doesn't correlate with your thumbnail
which doesn't correlate with your first sentence
of your video two you can't judge the Performance
Based on your CTR which is your clicky rate this
does have a minor role to play but it is not
as important as avd which is your average view
duration as well as the engagement which on likes
comments and shares but what counts the most is
how many people click from the end of your video
onto another one this is super important if you
are the reason for someone staying on YouTube for
longer YouTube will favor that three is dubbing in
multiple languages this is a no-brainer basically
the more languages your videos are dubbed in equal
the more amount of views you're gonna get. Four
something known as the churn this means sticking
to an exact upload schedule at the exact time
we have worked out that every 21 days works for
the Beast philanthropy Channel while Jimmy is in
the process of testing weekly when he can but he
always uploads at the same time on the same day
and lastly the length of the video as long as
the video is over 8 minutes and 1 second long
this gives YouTube the ability to place two ads
throughout the video which it obviously
prefers over one identifiable characters
throughout all of MrBeasts videos there are
the same characters this helps the audience
develop personal relationships with not just MrBeast but he's Supporting Cast as well they add
the additional X Factor and help with the banter
this also reaches a wider audience as there are
so many more character types to relate to you
can also play around with using the most liked
character later in your video to up the AVD as
there is an expectation to see him or her in the
video many YouTubers use this technique to drive
the story forward a character gives us the reason
to care each time we see one of these characters
in the videos we feel more involved in the main
character's life As We somewhat understand
what it is like to be his or her friend by
doing this it definitely makes your videos easier
to make as is less pressure on you to act alone.
Make movies to make money to make more movies this
is something that Walt Disney said but also an
ethos that Jimmy lives by as well as myself if
the purpose of your life of your content is to
make as many as possible you have to do whatever
it takes financially even if it means using your
entire budget obviously outside of what you
need to pay for your day-to-day expenses or
your monthly overheads based paid for anything
you need to Outsource the best investments you
can make in the creative industry is in your
personal brand story equals retention the number
one rule I have is that story comes first however
story is a very misunderstood term stories have to
have four elements one identifiable characters two
significant moments three authentic emotions and
four specific details you have to ask yourself
what is the story that you're trying to tell
what is the emotion that you're trying to convey
how are you going to convey this emotion to the
audience and Jimmy has started to adapt and evolve
his content by adding more story to it previously
although his philanthropy videos had great ideas
they lacked in story as well as aesthetic one of
the reasons he brought me onto the philanthropy
channel was to try and convey the emotion that
these films deserve to have to actually make the
audience feel something Jimmy is now trying to
bring more of the storytelling approach into the
main Channel videos developing a story will not
only create a more complete video but it will also
help build retention storytelling techniques like
foreshadowing and conflict allow the audience to
stay engaged until the end of the film this also
gives his videos more structure and at the end
of the day a good story just makes the videos
so much more pleasant to watch and will make your
content stand out from all the others on YouTube
go to the end of this video please let me know by
writing BRU bar or something about the BRU Bar
in the comments below and I'll be giving away
one thousand dollars to one lucky person that
comments that below again a huge huge shout out
to House of Macadamias for making the BRU Bar
possible click on the link below to purchase yours
now like click on it right now purchase it other
than that don't forget you're awesome BRU and
I'll see you soon for a new video but for now you
can keep up to date with me and my missions
on the Beast Philanthropy Channel. bye [Music]